For movie lovers, there are a few cinematic
quotes that are always handy for breaking
the ice or amping up the drama of a casual
chat.
But many of the most commonly used movie phrases
are almost always misrepresented in conversation.
If you're one of those people who loves to
whip out a famous movie line at an opportune
time, you might want to make sure you're actually
quoting the films correctly.
Here are some of the widely mistaken movie
lines in Hollywood history.
"Mirror, mirror"
The world of animation changed the day Walt
Disney and his studio released Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs.
Certain aspects of this classic resonate with
audiences to this day, such as the poisoned
apple, true love's kiss—and the eternal
question "Mirror, mirror on the wall, who
is the fairest of them all?"
The problem is, no one actually says that
in the film.
What the Evil Queen actually asks is:
"Magic mirror on the wall, who is the fairest
one of all?"
Interestingly enough, in the Grimm brothers'
original story, the Queen says, "Mirror, mirror,
on the wall, who in this land is fairest of
all?"
So, hi-ho, hi-ho off to correct quoting you
go.
"Ohhh, you must be Grumpy."
"A bigger boat"
Steven Spielberg pioneered the summer blockbuster
in 1975 with Jaws, his terrifying tale of
a great white serial killer.
The eerie cello music, the poster, the characters,
and the quotes—they all made Jaws the classic
movie it is today.
The line that's most often cited from the
movie comes from Chief Brody, who discovers
the deadly creature is much bigger than they're
prepared for.
Most people quote his famous line from the
scene to say, "We're gonna need a bigger boat."
But what Brody really says there is:
"You're gonna need a bigger boat."
It's just a one-word difference, but it's
a toothy one even so.
"If you build it"
Field of Dreams was both a fantasy film and
a sports drama and is often given tribute
with the line "If you build it, they will
come."
But the truth of the matter is that the whispered
voice over never actually utters that phrase,
and what's actually said instead is:
"If you build it, he will come."
It's not quite as compelling in singular format,
so it's easy to see why people like to use
the "they" instead of "he," but if you're
looking for something more inclusive to spout
out, you can always use this line instead:
"People will come."
"Run, you fools"
Peter Jackson's Lord of the Rings trilogy
was a ground-breaking adaptation of J.R.R.
Tolkien's beloved novels and boasts an abundance
of quotable moments in the movies.
"PO-TAY-TOES"
The one that seems to be most-often mistaken
is from The Fellowship of the Rings.
Gandalf lovers often like to say "Run, you
fools!" but in reality, what our old wizard
pal actually says in the movie is:
"Fly, you fools!"
Why would he say that when none of his traveling
companions had wings?
Well, "fly" in old English means to flee.
Orrrrr maybe he was just foreshadowing the
arrival of the Eagles in movie three.
"Feel lucky, punk?"
No matter how many movies Clint Eastwood directs
or stars in, his fans will always remember
him as the Man with No Name from the spaghetti
Western scene and Harry Callahan from the
Dirty Harry series.
But as quotable as the latter character is,
fans often butcher his biggest line.
It's much easier to shorten the scene to state,
simply, "Do you feel lucky, punk?" when the
time is right, but what he actually says is:
"You've got to ask yourself one question:
'Do I feel lucky?'
Well, do ya, punk?"
Now that you know the proper dialogue, you
should feel lucky.
"Play it again"
Casablanca is one of the most cherished films
in American history and is known for being
exceptionally quotable.
You can thank the movie for this epic goodbye
line:
"Here's looking at you, kid."
And this go-to party toast:
"I think this is the beginning of a beautiful
friendship."
And let's not forget this lover's lament:
"Of all the gin joints in all the towns in
the world, she walks into mine."
But people tend to get it wrong when they
quote the film to say, "Play it again, Sam."
The misquote even became the title of Woody
Allen's 1972 comedy film.
But what Ilsa actually says upon walking into
the cafe is
"Play it once, Sam, for old time's sake."
"Play it, Sam.
Play 'As Time Goes By.'"
And when Rick wants to hear it again?
Well, this is what he really says.
"You played it for her you can play it for
me."
"Well I don't think I can…"
"If she can stand it I can stand it.
. PLAY IT!"
Hey, everybody makes mistakes!
"I am your father"
Star Wars is perhaps the biggest entertainment
franchise in the world—and it doesn't seem
to be stopping any time soon.
Aside from all the lightsabers and galaxy-saving,
the series contains a plethora of famous lines,
from "may the Force be with you" to "I have
a bad feeling about this."
The line that seems to get mixed up most often
is when people quote Darth Vader to tell Luke
Skywalker, "Luke, I am your father."
But that's a line straight out of the dark
side of audience's memories because what Vader
really says is:
"No.
I am your father!"
Now that you know the truth, the Force can
really be with you.
"Not in Kansas"
It only makes sense that one of the most famous
quotes in history comes from one of the most
iconic films in history: The Wizard of Oz.
When Dorothy arrives in Oz thanks to a tornado,
most people quote her to tell her dog Toto,
"I don't think we're in Kansas anymore."
But that must be some Wicked Witch wizardry
at play because what our ruby shoe-sporting
pal actually says is:
"Toto, I've a feeling we're not in Kansas
anymore."
If you've ever misread that line aloud, don't
worry.
At least you're not the scarecrow.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!